North
and South
oh hello there
I didn't see you I was busy
exercise
I'm your host Michael Cyril Creighton
and this is one killer question
[Music]
and there he was in his signature cap
and red coat
I said Gideon gooseberry
theater isn't the only thing that's
haunted
Mabel Charles
Oliver
and dark spirits of Their Own
Gwen and DDR I have a question yes which
character is the most haunted
I feel like Charles has bad luck
it's the most self-sabotaging out of the
whole group I feel yeah absolutely
absolutely I think he's haunted by
past failed relationships right you know
he says I think in like season one I
spend a year enjoying it and then four
years thinking of a way to get out of it
wow yeah so he has convinced himself
perhaps that he's not
worthy of or meant to have a healthy
relationship so he keeps sabotaging them
and yeah Charles is also haunted by
Brazos I think he can continually like
lives in that space and he's afraid to
to move on to do this Broadway show
that's smart like honestly what's more
haunting than a one-time success yeah
but let's talk about who's the real
haunted person in this whole episode and
that is Mr Jerry Blau Jerry Blau below
the haunted look in his face when he
tells any kind of story yes roasting a
rat oh no yes living in the Attica yeah
we're supposed to be directing the play
that he's now living in the Attic above
that's some trauma yeah he's saying some
yeah yeah Jerry Blau has seen some
yeah now could he potentially be
Oliver's Ghost of Christmas future are
we looking is Jerry Blau what Oliver
could turn into do you think you're so
smart absolutely I think that scares him
enough to
just kind of shakes him yeah the minute
the puppets come out yes yes it's like
oh God no maybe
Oliver's mind right he sees his future
failure in Jerry Blau and it wouldn't be
the first time
you're a failure Splash yeah exactly if
anyone in the show is accused of murder
he's going to cover for them because he
doesn't want his play to get shut down
that's right he doesn't want it to be
Kimber because kimber's the only one who
can really sing in the show sorry Bobo
how dare you say that in front of the
camera I feel like there's cracks in the
wall and he's just trying to stop all
the cracks at the same time right and
there's like a flood coming in and
there's like little just like yeah he's
up to the knees right now not looking
good yeah yeah right like and and
something that I don't think we've ever
really seen in Oliver before the the
ferocity of which right he will defend
anyone in his cast especially Loretta
who maybe killed Ben and there's an
amount of denial that has to happen but
yeah Oliver is no stranger to denial I
feel no not at all now let's talk about
Mabel oh gosh she's a mess Maples
Mabel's losing everything she's losing
her apartment she's lost her friends
right she lost her her job as a
podcaster right and the only person that
seems to be like hey come with me kid is
Cinda Cannon feels like she
always pushes people away but the two
people she let in are off doing other
things falling in love and putting up
Broadway shows and they don't have time
for the little pod that they built right
their relationships and the play and
she's kind of like on a solo Mission
yeah her past relationship's like you
know I think they really created a hard
exterior shell for Mabel and yeah
Charles and Oliver were the only people
in this world of hers that were able to
crack it and it's hard to lose her olds
oh totally and the fight at the end
between the trio is so upsetting it's
shattering yeah I cried it's like when
your parents fight you don't want them
to break up and you want them to get
back together and it was very
heartbreaking yeah and I'm gonna figure
out who did it whether the two of you
give a or not I'm done
what haunts you
oh God like in real life we're gonna be
real here for a second we can't just be
the comic relief let me say Okay
Filipinos are extremely superstitious
people and I personally
have felt unseen ghosts in my real life
really but honestly like okay there was
one night the the theater that I perform
at nightly on Broadway is one of the
most haunted theaters on Broadway really
and there was one night where I was on
stage with three people just three of us
and I feel a hand on my shoulder and I'm
like well that's weird like my My Scene
partner normally doesn't do that and I
look over at him and he is nowhere near
me
yikes at least they didn't push you into
the pit or anything that's true that's
true so that's good they're nice ghosts
yeah yeah I feel like I'm a every now
and then be haunted by ghosts
I do believe in ghosts for sure
I'm haunted by
fear
I think
what are you haunted by
failure failure
well guys this was a lot of fun yeah not
scary at all but we've got to move on
because it's time for one killer game
people think Gideon Gooseberry is a real
ghost Howard is one of them
let's play Gideon gooseberries ghost
stories
I'll start a story about Gideon
and then we're gonna pass it along
campfire Style
ready
thank you Gideon thank you
thank you
for Gideon to leave this realm and find
peace
he must
find
his daughter
and his daughter
was stolen away
in an old costume Trunk by the head
wardrobe mistress
cause
she wanted to have a family of her own
but couldn't have a family of her own
because she lacked so many eggs
so she took this girl
Lucy gooseberry
put her in that trunk and threw her in
the ocean
and then she
jumped in because she still wanted the
kid
and
a great whale swallowed them up I swear
it sounds it's like it sounds like
Pinocchio but it's not
and the whale
moved his bowels around to separate the
trunk from the evil wardrobe mistress
until they were on either side of his
rib cage because he has that much
control until finally
Gideon gooseberry
swam through the whale's nostril
and found his daughter
hooray hooray
weird good oh God oh God by myself again
thanks guys so much for being here and
playing these games can't wait to see
you again sometime
but for now
see you next time on one killer question
and until then try not to get haunted
[Music]
thank you